III 2015 is well underway and we got to
see a little bit of what Nintendo had to
show off I'm Justin this is peter and we
got to play starfox one of the most
exciting reveals from the Nintendo
Direct presentation but actually getting
to play it maybe not so much yeah this
was the biggest game of the show both
for Nintendo if for me personally and
going into this I was so excited the
presentation looked great you know we
found out that they're actually making
this game with platinum games which is
also one of my favorite developers so I
went when went in with really high hopes
but wow the holes were i'd say confusing
and you know I've played a lot of Star
Fox and if you're a very big star fox
fan yeah and it felt like they've
created a problem that the series never
had before just so they can justify the
gamepad being an integral part of the
wii u it it's something that Nintendo I
think does a lot they have really great
hardware and they want to give you a
reason to use its platoon was it was
very similar when I started out playing
splatoon I didn't like the motion
controls I was like I you know I'm a
regular gamer I'm gonna turn this off
and play it normally but then after
doing that for maybe half an hour I was
like actually the motion controls make
it better and and it didn't take me that
long to get the hang of it to feel like
motion controls add to this experience I
still necessarily like to play it like
when I'm relaxing at home because it's a
very active you're in you're moving the
controller a lot starfox even though we
had a pretty extended time amount of
time to get used to the game i I never
got used to it like I just wanted to
turn it off the entire time like so the
way that it works is you have to hold
your controller up and have the screen
right in front of you and you're just
kind of constantly looking back and
forth between them while also moving the
controller yeah you're very you're very
engaged which is a good thing but not
necessarily in a good way yeah I mean so
you have those two setups because the
top screen is meant for actually flying
your ship right maneuvering around the
environment around obstacles but then if
you really want to fire effectively
that's when you go into the cockpit view
because the line of sight for the
reticle is right from there and you know
you think okay I had the reticle over
the guy in the TV view you can still aim
while moving you'd think that it would
hit the enemy it kept missing even when
the reticle was right on him and the guy
told me because you should switch to the
cockpit view that gives you the right
perspective I mean yes it's definitely
confusing
but let's at least talk about what else
is in the game because there's more than
just confusing controls here yeah I'm
controls aside the level of detail in
the backgrounds was really great I like
I loved flying through corneria and I
mean having a level of detail that we're
never able to get with previous Nintendo
games and seeing the city seeing the the
level of destructibility the huge
enemies that you're flying against the
multi tiers of bosses like there's still
a lot that's very impressive about Star
Fox yeah and we also got to see some of
the new vehicles uh well the arwing is
not a new vehicle but it has a feature
that has not been any previously
released our Fox I can't remember that
it has been I don't think it has
transforming into the was the land
Walker on the art either way you
transform into a mech I can't remember
the name right now but that's okay so
you literally press the a button and you
flip from being a plane into a walking
Mac and that lets you you know fly into
ships and crawl through little corridors
to maybe find a secret or take on
enemies more close up rather than having
to fly overhead and swoop around them
and we also got to play around with some
of the other vehicles in the game there
was the landmaster tank and there was
kind of a floaty thing at the gyro wing
it's essentially a drone but it has a
drone of its own it can drop a little
robot that's tethered to it looks a lot
like rob the robot actually the old
nintendo accessory which they've also
announced new bows for apparently and
with that you can again explore little
corridors and try to find stuff i mean
there is a lot to do in the starfox game
beyond just flying a ship and shooting
at other ships coming at you the success
of this game is really going to come
down to the controls and you know we're
going to be finding out soon if you can
use the pro controller which
unfortunately they weren't able to
answer during that event but we're going
to speaking to the Platinum Games
director who also worked on Bayonetta 2
and speaking of platinum games they've
been working with the Star Fox team in a
lot of different capacities so you had
those that smaller robot game that we
were dealing with they're going to be
doing project guard which we saw last
year which has some connection to Star
Fox not totally sure what that is but
Platinum Games says that the gameplay is
finished we just need to see what the
game is going to be probably sometime
next year yeah so with a lot of talent
behind Star Fox it's still reasonable to
have high hopes but initial impressions
are a little rough so Justin thank you
for joining me and stick with gamespot
for the rest of you three for all your
gaming news